رفوف شبه خاليه بريطانيا تشكو نقصا في
متاجر الفاكهه والخضار ازمه قد تمتد
لاسابيع وربما لشهر وعلى اثرها قيدت اربع
شركات كبرى مشتريات متسوقين من بعض
المنتجات كطماطم والخيار والخس والفلفل
والبروكلي والقرنبيط والتوت وقصرتها على
علبتين واقصاها ثلاث علب لكل زبون الحكومه
طمنت ان تقنين الامدادات جاء لضمان قدره
جميع المستهلكين على شراء احتياجاتهم اما
وزيره البيئه فاسدت نصيحه امام البرلمان
وقالت كل اللفت بدلت التفكير في الخس او
الطماطم
من المهم التاكد من اننا نثمن منتجات
بلادنا فالكثير من الناس سياكلون اللفت في
الوقت الحالي
نصيحه لاقت سخريه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي حيث تداول المستخدمون صوره
لخريطه بريطانيا يغطيها اللفت اما دول
الجوار فتكتسي بالطماطم وصوره اخرى تقول
ان اللفت نفد من المخزون واخرى لقطيع من
المشي ياكل اللفت للعشب اما عن تخصيصها
اللفت فهو من اكثر المنتجات الموسميه التي
تتميز بها بريطانيا وبما ان مشكله التوريد
تعود الى سوء الاحوال الجويه في جنوبي
اوروبا وشمالي افريقيا قررت وزيره البيئه
بكل بساطه ان تثمن انتاج مزارع بريطانيا
رغم انها كانت قد تعرضت لعاصفه انتقادات
في سبتمبر الماضي حينها اتهمها المغردون
بالتناقض فكيف لوزيره صحه ان تدخن